tiennent bon soir alors pas de hausse de
taux a dit la fed aujourd'hui avant 2022
chute du pib de 6 et demi pourcent fort
rachat d'obligations de bons du trésor
qu'est ce que vous captez aujourd'hui du
message la réserve fédérale 1 le message
il 5 c au maine priorité du côté de des
chômeurs on parle de 22 à 24 millions
chômeurs présentement aux états unis et
des parures veut vraiment le plus
rapidement passé permettre à la plupart
des gens de retrouver le même os qu'ils
avaient avant la pandémie et adore de
retrouver avec un nouvel emploi contenu
que des entreprises très exposés
commencé à l'aco vide
donc on a senti l'aspect du marché du
travail comme étant à la clé au cours
des prochains trimestres la réserve
fédérale et on a senti donc que ça va
prendre du temps et que la fed va devoir
en faire plus et que le gouvernement
fédéral américain devra en faire plus
aussi
tout à fait je pense qu'on en fait
beaucoup en disant justement on veut
maintenir les taux près de zéro pendant
les prochaines années même si on sait
pas encore de quoi va voir là la
deuxième vague potentiellement cet
automne donc vous pouvez pas changer le
le bateau de direction aujourd'hui du
côté de la réserve fédérale compte tenu
de l'incertitude par rapport à la
deuxième vague donc mieux rassurer les
gens du symbole quand même écraser les
taux d'intérêt on va acheter de la dette
corporative en acheter des obligations
du fédéral maintenir une liquidité de
l'eau au moulin permettent aux banques
de 2 soutenu le crédit quand la pythie à
ce qui est crédible de paix reviendra de
la part des consommateurs qui sont très
anxieux présentement
donc c'est vraiment pour moi le message
clair de tenir aujourd'hui on est à quoi
deux mille milliards d'actifs racheté
par la réserve fédérale
oui et au cours des derniers mois par le
2000 milliards 7 milliards en tout
contenu des achats évidemment des années
passées mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
facilement aux milliards même mignon
perdons donc on parle de vitesse grand v
parce que d'ici la fin de l'année tout
dépendant
notamment de la thonade la reprise dans
l'autre c'est dur a fallu sont
aujourd'hui bien la réserve fédérale
peut avoir dans ses livres de l'ordre
d'environ 10000 à 12000 milliards de
titres vraiment travailler donc c'est
beaucoup l'ont fait pas jouer certaines
des feux on met de l'eau même sur des
fugues sont pas encore connus mais c'est
ce qui compte présentement parce que on
le le président réserve fédérale de bien
dit aujourd'hui est ce qu'on veut éviter
la destruction permanente d'entreprise
c'est des gens qui sont présents ont
perdu leur emploi de manière temporaire
se retrouve sans impôts pendant six à
douze mois on parle plutôt de 2 du taux
de perte permanents ont donc c'est
vraiment l'enjeu de l'emploi de la
disparition par an celle qui ira
j'y parle vraiment vraiment inquiets ces
jours ci et donc il dit le taux de
chômage à 5 % ça ira à la fin de 2022
assez négatif aussi quand même sur la
prévision économique cette année et le
rebond à 5% 2021 est ce que c'est pas un
peu plus faible qu'on pensait non
honnêtement je fais très mal positionné
pour vous dire ces prisons de la
fédération trois ans miss ou pessimiste
en fait le chômage de taman surpris à la
marge que la réserve fédérale lui dise
que je mens je redescends même à 5 % en
2020 une bulle ce que la reprise de 2 5%
de l'économie l'an prochain ça dépendra
de comment les consommateurs américains
auprès du tout la même chose des
consommateurs canadiens vont dépenser
les pales de précaution qu'il met
présentement côté ont conduit les
négociations différentes et que des
paroles n'étaient pas capables de
comparer ce qui se passe présentement la
grande dépression il a raison dans la
mesure où des gens ce pot qui peuvent
pas dépenser y en a qui peuvent pas des
français qui préfèrent pas contenue que
c'est repos 1 leur santé quelle est leur
position d'ici six à douze points
également ce qu'on voit encore un emploi
d'ici six à douze mois cet apport de
précaution là pour être utilisé à à
payer des romans les choses dans ma
quotidienne est simple industrie mais ça
ça va que beaucoup de gens sont rappelés
à paris
employant à ce moment là les dépenses
discrétionnaires pour prendre le dessus
c'est à ce moment que à ce moment là par
donc la reprise va être beaucoup plus
robuste est ce qu on mesure bien l'effet
potentiel d'une deuxième vague de
contagion selon vous
du côté de l'oci dès aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé fort intéressant de voir que
l'impact d'une deuxième bague serez pas
nécessairement majeur pour 2020 mais le
mal est fait mais ce serait plutôt sur
la reprise en 2021 et l'on revient à 10
quand le père fédéral essentiellement
sur la disparition capital qui est
présentement huit feux dans l'économie
le lien entre les employeurs et les
employés à est vraiment se mènerait une
erreur par retard considérable sur les
attentes des gens par rapport à une
reprise et à ce moment là on pourrait
parler plutôt d'une d'une dépression
plutôt que d'une récession non ce qu'on
peut retenir aujourd'hui en fête de
l'eau cellule réserve fédérale qui ne
savent pas encore quand tu sauves a
arrêté un spiral l'addition
désinvestissent à une écoute vraiment
vraiment de cela prendre ces jours-ci
absolument fait passer la voix merci
pour cette analyse ce soir au plaisir
gerald